If you actually take a look at
what the Amy are already per
transported load, the invitation unit
is certainly a thread actually relatively green, but
we also have to
reduce our emissions significantly, yes, and
at some point we have to get to zero,
of course, fuel is incredibly
important, but it's not the only thing
but at the end of the day, these green
fuels are not yet available in large
quantities
and that will probably
take another ten or 20 years and
that means that we still
have to focus on efficiency today small
podcast excursion into a completely different one
Industry today, in
shipping or something like that. Shipping company business,
no industries that I have
dealt with very much so far because
I am well versed, but I was very
curious because the most successful, largest,
most important German shipping company number five
in the world, namely Papa, is running on the
last  year a result produces a
result of 18 billion euros so
profitably no other German company has earned so much money
I also never think and that I recently someone
I can actually be what kind of
business model is Rederei actually
so how do you make the money  what are
the costs where do all the ships come from does
a ship cost everything I wanted to
know and was able to meet
directly at the traditional
Hapag trunk in Hamburg in Rolf
Jansen have people and it was a very
instructive conversation, among other things,
pirates also came up a lot  others let's go
hello
good morning
you actually grew up in shipping, so to speak,
at least in
forwarding, no, you were born in the Netherlands,
but you've always worked in logistics
forwarding, that's
actually true for over 30 years, at the
beginning with nice people, then for a long time
with DHL and  after that and since meanwhile it's
nine years old again and you came
to Hapag Lloyd uh when the company
was actually on the bottom, you could say that
those were at least very, very difficult
years like 2014 was that you come here yes
I can imagine in the middle of the crisis yes
and at that time the situation was of course
incredibly difficult, back then the
merger was initiated with a very, very great
idea and that was a
very important step forward for us
and since then it has of course
developed well, but I mean before we
talk about the present day and
about the  Development from 2014 to today,
so I have to say that the marketing is now
50 billion, so it's also one of the
most valuable German films ever,
how high was the market cap,
I don't remember exactly, but
when the stock market went up, then
I think our market cap was 1,  5 or
two billion, so it was the year
you came, you did the first IPO,
no, we did it together first
and we
all went public in 2015, but still
the companies valued the goodwill for about
50 times  in the last few years but
exactly but on the basis of a huge
tradition like dad or people hapak
people sits yes then at some point have
become one in Germany a
huge tradition because of course that
already yes I mean habakleute really has
a name internationally too of course I mean we are  also not for nothing
already 100 almost 176 years since yes so
therefore yes act a
traditional speech as everyone
says and also in the market that
changes again and again and have people
who actually changed with it
and that's the way it has to be started
it's with sailing ships from Hamburg to
the USA, I think that's where the
name Papa comes from, American Parcel
or Parcel Company, and then there was
sailing and then it just
developed for many years and then it was
actually almost over before that
you came it was so that you thought
the company would really outlive itself so
it wasn't that bad again
but in 2014 or shortly after the
crisis the toilet just stood like all the other
shipping companies
that was just difficult yes and we
were actually  right in the middle of the crisis
and it could have ended differently
why was it so difficult at the time so
what what is, so to speak, the cycle
of shipping depends on my
cycle in shipping everything ultimately depends
on supply and demand in
2009 we of course had the big one
At the time of the crisis, everyone expected
that there would be a lot of growth, so
there were a great many new orders
from you, ships that
came and okay, then there were just
far too many ships for the
offer and then you just see them
go  the rates in the basement and
then everyone fought
is a shipping in which they are
a cyclical business in the sense that it
always moves in the rhythm of the
economy and or how will it
not exactly in the rhythm of the economy
but it is certainly a  very cyclical
business that's right okay well
HAPAG which I don't think a lot of people even
know was still something to do back then
so we know TUI today as a
holiday company
but for a long time it was the biggest scissors or
from Harput people surprising yes but
that was easy  for many years
it worked well for many years,
but then sometime in
2008 there was an
attempt by an Asian
shipping company to take over hapak and then
this work came about
where some people got on and the TUI
more partially dropped out of
course  After that I still had
over 20% that I came and the last
20% were sold in 2016 I think
that wasn’t so smart
I mean in hindsight you’re always
smarter yes I think back then it was
for TUI was the good yes they  at
that time they sold it for a decent price they
were also
getting out so
it was a good decision at the time
and what has happened over the last two
and a half years
nobody could have foreseen today at that again
briefly  to explain it belongs to
dad people um mr mr bold so the
German logistics billionaire it belongs
in parts of the city of Hamburg it is
parts listed on the stock exchange who still owns it and
in addition it also very much belongs to SV that
's a me that's the Chilean
speech purely with whom we merged yes
in 2014 and in addition, that also includes
two investments from us in the Middle
East, yes, I think that's
one for the cat in Abu Dhabi and one for
the Saudi, okay, so these are the
investment funds that are now also
going into startup companies and
German industry in general  you buy packages, so to speak,
diversify, so that means
you got them and how do you manage to
go from, I know, two billion market cap to 50
or more or what was the
development of the last few years, I think
if you look at the last few years
then the most important thing was actually
these two merges that we did,
first with a lot of methods in 2014 that gave
us a huge boost because
after that we were actually always profitable except for a
year. In 2017 we
then doubled again with the
merching with Oase with it  we have
achieved a bigger one, which also
makes us competitive and
in the last few years, even before the
pandemic, I actually had
decent results and we would
also be compared to, for example, our
Danish colleagues from the first or the
French colleagues from CEMA
we actually at least on an equal footing
so the development was good until 2019
2020 then they all thought at first
now everyone is talking about bankruptcy yes
because the demand then dropped very sharply
but then of course there was
this completely
unexpected boom yes because everyone from the
to  Working at home suddenly
needed new furniture and and and and
the demand was incredibly strong from the end of
2020 to, let's say, the middle of last
year and that led to this enormous
boom okay, so you act like
it's not your merit,
of course that doesn't happen  everything we
didn't do anything wrong yes
and that's also why we were
relatively good yes also
good before the pandemic in 2018/2019 so we
certainly did some things right when it
comes to the two of them in particular
I would say very very FAU  and and oasis
and and otherwise we have, i think,
modernized, digitized, and the
bottom line, i think i have also
become more competitive in
recent years, such a
consolidation market, so you got that
out of your hands, yes, then mercury
bought there, so the big shipping companies
are buying each other right now
A lot has happened in the last 10 years, because
after the crisis, I mean you
mentioned it back in 2014. At that time, there were
still almost 20 global shipping companies,
but since then, 87 have disappeared, yes,
because of Murger, we played our part
but also others I
always bought my ten API March
bought Hamburg-Süd so yes then at
some point it will go broke sooner hand
so you can estimate the
world market
pretty well according to my layman’s idea
simply based on the number of ships
and ship you can  don't hide it so
that's why you should know exactly how
many large merchant ships there are
actually
I don't know that either I
know that the fleet worldwide is
a little over 20 million do so that's how
we measure it these are the
containers these are the containers are  24
units 40 foot container 2 and I think
that the bottom line is that the
average size is
between 4 and 5000 tu of all shepherds
worldwide and that means that
I think we are 6000 ships anyway, about
6000 ships does
n't sound that much for the whole  world and all
those who help out there, you have
how many of them we have about 200
150 okay, so somehow 5% of
global trade if you then
look at what that means about
capacity then we have vice versa 7.5%.
when we look at our market share
we always say we are not active in the
gateway or hardly active in Asia and
if you don't include that in the
assessment market share of around
10% and how is your business doing so
in the end that is yes you can see
quite simply imagine you
were shipped no matter what from one
port to the next and then have
certain freight numbers that he makes so
intra-asia don't tell yourself what
your strongest route i think the
strongest we end up
some questions traditional Hartberg
very strong between  Europe and
North America, so on the transatlantic
but also since the merchem with
the Chilean shipping company in particular,
we are also very strong from and
to Latin America or India, I
would say for us it is a
market where we have developed very well over the years
as is going  because then there is
sales or business development and you
just give up and offer, look for companies that
want to ship new goods and
then you try to offer yourself as a
potential service provider
or call the others or what about
a bit of everything I mean,
first of all we have we  basically have
two groups of customers we have the
direct customers yes they are, let me say,
the IKEA, the BMWs and so on from this world
who book directly with us uh then there are
also many forwarders yes monastery of
our business runs through forwarders
basically I would say
roughly  35% are direct customers
and 65% are via forwarders and then
we also have the whole
online channel, which used to be completely
insignificant, but since 2018 you can
actually simply
request a coding online and book it with habak
and that’s what I think is now
The last thing I saw is 25
or 27% of our business is
your homepage, so to speak, then he
immediately puts his mask directly as the start page
and then I have the feeling I could
somehow send a container
from I don't know many to
Hamburg or vice versa  it seems
a bit like ebay
is also really short and you
can simply make a uh request a rate
from A to B wherever you
want to go and you can
book directly afterwards and you always
talked about it beforehand  whole topic of
digitization and unicorns and and and
somehow it's the same with
us because I have my 2018
we are actually allowed and in 2020
I think I got
2 billion more sales through this online channel
okay okay from how much sales
all in all if you look back then if you
were in 2020 that was 15 percent of
our business back then our
total turnover was about 15 billion
okay um how do you differentiate a
shipping business so in the end it’s a
question of accessibility so you have to think
about it  Website can easily book with you I
understand, um then I assume
the price is a huge criterion is it
the time how quickly you
can do it or the security or what are
the different factors I think if you
of course the price is important yes then
in the end it has to  price in the market
but if you
want to further develop the business and if you
want to grow with customers and then
in the end quality is also incredibly
important are a bit exactly so that
if you buy something privately and you
have two options and they have
the same price and  with one of them
you get good service and with the
other you no longer have any service, then
the decision is usually
made quickly and
it’s just no different with shipping,
we see that right now the
market is significantly weaker again, I
think we basically have
we deliver good quality, although of course
one or the
other thing goes wrong with us,
but that's why you can now feel
Nikon's loyalty and that's also why we can
still deliver a relatively good performance
when you say good quality or  something is going
wrong so what does what mean now for
the line so it simply means that you
deliver on time or somehow
things break or what is
quality, so to speak, of course it's
punctual delivery is super important
that was incredibly difficult in the last few years
because of all the traffic jams  there
was help all around and disruptions
because of korit but it's also about
simple things because if you
call us you have to pick up the phone
and if you send an e-mail then
you have to try to
answer quickly and those are things  it
all sounds very natural,
but we all know that sometimes
things like this are not that easy and
I believe in this area and
even when it comes to issuing
correct invoices again, we provide the correct
documents on time and and
and there we have
Really great progress has been
made over the last few years and you can see that when you
look at the feedback from the customers, what is mainly in your
containers, i.e. what is
mainly transported by you, I
would say about everything, I
mean, it also depends a bit  it depends on where
it comes from but that really goes from
furniture to clothing to chemicals to
water also grain or or yes I
mean you can have a lot of vegetables yes all
yes and what does the container cost
if I
want to have Rede Nero driven from here somehow
I wouldn't know that off the top of my head,
yes, but the bottom line is,
if you look at the major
routes, you'll see that
I'll say between Asia and Europe,
you'll normally always
be able to book a container for somewhere around
2,000 dollars  or a little less and that
is of course for a 40 foot container
yes in which you can transport a relatively large amount,
the protona is
really relatively little and that is why
the whole container business has
developed so well over the years the
bottom line is it is simply a very
efficient transport model are reality  Have
you ever taken a ride on
one of those ships on its route? I've
often been on the ship on the
ride. Okay, um, but there are about
15,000 employees
while the majority end up on the
ships or are they the people in the
office, no, we  there are bigger ones
then there are more people in the
office yes we have offices in about 135
countries and the whole processing of
sales costs you
just need a lot of people even if it
has become more and more efficient over
the years and  Of course, we
also have the people on board the ships, but
a very simple extrapolation: 250
potheads, now we have about 25 people
on board, the classic
sailors and the mostly German
people from some countries, it
’s about the officers and the  Captains,
then, there are a lot of Europeans,
we still have a
lot of ships flying the German flag, yes,
but the crews also come from
India, the Philippines and and and and that
's simply because they end up
doing it for less money and
logically  I mean that in the end
you have different jobs and for
some jobs you wo
n't find many people here in Europe who
actually want to do it, of course, for a
long time away from home, yes,
and then you see that there are simply
certain countries where  there are a lot of people
who still like to do it and
there are, for example, a lot of
bees under and in her, there
are a lot of them and once with
the flag, it depends on whether a
ship sails under the German flag
among other things flag I as I
followed is also as a layer always think
the tax reasons that have been founded
in my we have always I
mean we are a German shipping company
and we have always known for the
German flag because we also believe that
it is important that  shipping is
actually still strong in
Europe and that's why we always
have about 100 of our own ships
and a little less than
half of them are actually always flying the German
flag and that also means that we
train many German seafarers and
also in and when  It is particularly about
our officially we need a lot of
German ladies and we are also
happy with that. It also fits with our
image where we say we are
quality-minded yes and the tract is
really to
buy a new ship is what
a ship costs if  the flag
that expands the fleet is
always
bigger, but when I
look back we have plans for 2020 to
buy 21 new ships, some of them weighing
up to 24,000 kilos, and at
some point you
pay around 165 million dollars for that
that's thinking
and what to do
if I think I won't buy them anymore
but if you have you because if it's so
cyclical that then suddenly
sometimes I mean there you came
we can breathe a little because I
think we have something  over 100
properties but
we also rent or cake ships because
in total our fleet is about 250
of them 100 15 I think about our own
ships the rest we have to rent, so
to speak and that also means that
if there is less demand then
you would  just give some of these rented
ships back because that is
actually the flexibility you have
and how long is the ship durable
then so how long can that be for
you to sail
if you buy a new ship you have to
assume that you will use it for about
25 years  ok really also here on the
computer and closes the calculation says
ok on the route there is
so much demand there we can
use another ship like this then there is an
order then it will take a few years
or until then it would be
that simple it would be better
but in the end it is like this you have to
make a decision where we think
it will go in the medium term, the market is
very difficult to assess in a two year period and you
just have to have the belief that over the
next 20 25 years you will need certain ships
you also have to modernize the fleet
because a ship that you
need nowadays consumes super and
also consumes significantly less
fuel more from the ship what I would say
is 20 years old and also
because of that you have to bottom line
also cheaper or more efficient
you have  actually tracked that there are
now 9 so uh ship fuel
so on with the zero bars there are
so many different new startups
somehow called C1 one of them even has I
think more competitors invested
the colleague who founded the
podcast recently do you watch something like that they
all the sustainability efforts for
us it's also um that's one of
our four main topics when it comes to
our strategy because you should
n't forget that although sometimes people do
n't talk so positively about
shipping when you actually
look at what the Amy are already and
per transported load, the loading
unit is actually
relatively green, nevertheless,
we also have to reduce our emissions significantly,
yes, and at some point we have to
get to zero, because fuel is
of course incredibly important, but it
is not the only thing, but in the end
these green fuels are
not yet in large numbers  Quantities are
simply not available and that will
probably take another ten or 20
years and that means that we
still have to focus on efficiency today
and take all sorts of measures
to ensure that in the
end we need less fuel and we
we  For example, we also use bio yes, which
also helps us to
reduce emissions and we have built our new cheer
can also run on liquid
or do you have to if you need a new engine is
just
difficult yes we have seen quite a change
between the fuel on LNG  In
hindsight, it was so expensive that you
will never do it again, yes, but I do believe
that with some of these
new fuels,
especially when it comes to meta knowing,
it should actually be technically possible
to unequip them against a reasonably
acceptable cost  To be
fair, I have to say that I am
convinced of it, but I think when I say that to
our technicians,
they say that it shouldn't say yes,
and then tell me about this other innovation
Sailing, a kind of
parachute anyway, because they are then hanging in front of them so
that they are open, so to speak,
not only operated by the engine
but also really pulled by the wind
and something like that, yes, that would be great if
it worked and I would
also say we  are also studying
for one or the other service whether there is a
possibility to do something with the wind,
yes, the normal rule will
probably not work,
the ships are simply too big and too
heavy and the contribution is too small
and one should not
forget even if  everyone always talks
about the lock-voting panic for
still with about 16 knots or something
and that also means that wind would not
always
help a lot okay that means
for you to make the industry more sustainable at the moment you have
to observe this development in fuel
making the ships more efficient means
loading them even better, that you
have to drive less and more fits on a
ship or is it a
combination I mean we can also use
all sorts of technical options
to make the shepherds more efficient
I mean we just got the last one  year
a program is connected that means a
heating fleet improvement program
we're turning another 6,700 million
and for these 6,700 million we
hope in two three years
seven to nine percent
fuel pigs you can say that
's only 7 to 9%.  but still yes that
you understand what we use and if we
need less fuel
we will also
be able to do this sooner with green
fuel and Bio view, for example,
also makes a contribution from I guess
that we will  Year five to seven
percent of our total
fuel will be bio-view and if
you add the two together then
you’re back at 15 percent,
so fuel is an important
cost item for you, so you look,
the turnover comes from the freight rates,
logically  So what you
charge your customers but
what are your costs that is the
depreciation on the ships
probably what it is I mean it
is depreciation on the ships that
is actually fuel there are also
the handling costs in the port  are
also the domestic traffic and then
of course it is also
IT and personnel
have you looked at that is a
big discussion also like to
compensate things so so to speak we are doing
a festival of considering how now also
compensation yes or no
probably with you too  one topic is
he doing something like that or have you
decided against or I think our
approach is now to
try to reduce emissions
yes and for this efficiency
programs for LNG there helps with of
you and we will also green products
on the  Bringing it to the market
you also have the opportunity to buy such products from us,
in fact,
we don’t do the offsetting, because we believe
that in the end it is important
to reduce emissions, yes, so just to say, okay,
then I neutralized them in the accounting
In the end, our
output is still high, yes,
in absolute terms, and we simply have to reduce it
if we have made so much profit now, you
can read about it in the
peak year 201
because we have
we have parts, of course we also
paid our shareholders back because we
also pay one  very decent
dividend but we have also
invested a lot over the last few years, for
example in more modern ships, yes,
we ordered 22 new ships in total,
I think that is a
big commitment when it comes to
capital, we also had to buy a lot of
containers, because
especially  during the pandemic it took
me a very long time before you
actually get a container back
so to transport the same amount then
you need a lot more and
forth so we bought about half a million
additional boxes
and we also invested in
helping yes then  what we have known for a long time
but learned again during the pandemic is
that it is very
important that you also have access
to capacity or that you can get in at the port
to actually
load and unload the boxes and that is why
we have  also in help
partly invested here in Germany but also
for example in Morocco in Egypt
in South America and in India that means
the value added chain is extended a bit
because port logistics
then buys that is a
value added stage, so to speak, which then
follows on from your yes and  The thinking
behind it is simply that you are
therefore able
to offer a better product to the customer, yes, and we
see that here in Hamburg too, for
example because we have had a
stake in the Altenwerder container towers for a long time
and that just helps us
enormously and our position
to assert and further
strengthen here in Germany and also to have a good application,
for example in Europe, you would
always have a lot of
globalization and that is all a
bit declining because of
all the geopolitical problems with
Russia and China and such  Do you
already notice that trade has also simply
reduced, that there is simply not
so much going back and forth between affected countries?
I do
n't think so, I mean at the moment the demand has been
weak, yes, over the last four five
months, but I think that's more likely  a
correction because you also hear everywhere
that we have
really felt the camps in many
countries in the last few years and that will have to be reduced again at some point
and that is why
demand is less strong these days,
which I do believe is that
many companies will move after the pandemic
think carefully about how I would like to
actually organize my supply chains
and maybe I would
not only like to be dependent on China but
maybe also get some of my goods
from Turkey or India or
Vietnam and I think that is
more the change that you can make  and
in the future everything will actually be
produced locally here in Germany.
I have to doubt that if you
order new ships now with the greatest
goal that you just described, then
he doesn't just do it because the money is there,
but also because we obviously
believe that  you need more so
it's already a clear assumption that
it will continue to expand but
because partly that's partly
a bit of growth but it's
mainly because we have
to replace old ships I mean we're
slowly getting towards the 20
Ships that are
close to you for 25 years
and that also means that you don’t
have to take them out at some point.
On the one hand, this helps because we then need less
fuel, on the other hand, it also helps us
because the piece was therefore also
the unit costs
will then be further reduced in this famous
incident now  during the pandemic the channel is called
this evergift and this ship was
distributed, so to speak,
ships from you were also in the
queue, it was clear yes we also had
ships in the queue at the end
it took six days of course it was
very present in the press
but to be fair I think  not that such
an incident, it was discussed very intensively,
but it only made a very
small contribution, yes, it only made a
very small contribution to the destruction
in the global supply chains, because
a six-day delay like that can knock
it out in two months, yes  can this be
solved again okay that means the longer
supply chain destruction time was
caused by the fact that the helpers were not allowed to be
used at all i think in
China and so ne mean they were allowed to help
and are already being used but what you have
already seen during the pandemic
what that was that in particular
productivity has gone down and
I can understand that because in
many help there were all sorts of
additional rules about what you
can and cannot do,
also because of all the quarantine rules
there were of course fewer staff
available, so the capacity is
from  the help in practice
has gone down yes and if the capacity
goes down okay then you get traffic jams
if that if the offers
basically stay the same so
it is also no coincidence that the
traffic jams have cleared up relatively
quickly after this curve caused
restrictions no longer  since the
last one, trade is back to
normal, so to speak, that's what I did before the pandemic,
I would say yes and you think
it will remain at the same level in the next few years,
so it won't get any stronger. There
is new growth in world trade, but
there isn't any drastic growth either  I do believe
that there will still be growth.
I still believe that this
is the trend, that
world trade develops roughly with the
Globo GdP, and if the
global economy grows three percent every year,
I do believe that on average
that too  container traffic
will grow by maybe two percent,
that's a trend, they've had me
for a very long time, and sometimes when there's
a crisis then there's a
deviation at the front, but the trend itself
is still there, I think, that will
only be growth from China  no
probably rather not likely
that he comes from somewhere else but the
bottom line uh countries like India and
Africa and South America that will
continue to grow yes you see your
acquisitions or your partnerships
then you have the feeling you are
very strong in Africa so there's only
then we can know research
new
yes takeovers I think Africa
trading company or such
companies that have now increased in
my Africa it is certainly an issue we
have now taken over two smaller shipping companies
over the last two years
we also believe that it is a market
the next 10 to 20 years will see
above-average growth and that's
why we have to make sure
that we have a certain position there.
India is also very important to us
if you
look at what we've invested in
Africa and in India, all in all we've
invested more in India, yes  Of
course, in Africa the market is also
larger
and it also has an incredible desire
for growth, but if you
look at the size of India today and
you compare it with China before
then both countries are in China and
you have 1.3 million people in  India
has I think 1.6 or 1.7 depending
on which statistic you believe
but the container volume in China is
I think four or five
times as big as India and that does
n't mean that India is
necessarily four times as much  worth it but
that it has doubled or
tripled over the last 20 years
I think so and tell me this
great result from yes here
Hamburger my city benefits and
yes taxpayers and all sorts of that
comes about because the demand
has been so strong during  the
pandemic that you then say okay then
we’ll just hear the prices like that
in the market somewhere there is a demand you
could increase the prices in the phase or for
a few years so that your
margin was then so strong and suddenly
had 18 centuries
under  Bottom line, yes, although of course they did
n't increase the rates for everyone either,
I mean, it's often
talked about that the containers
were 10 or 20 times as expensive, yes, before that,
I don't think that's quite fair, I
think it was at the peak
So the average rate here is about 2.5 times
higher than before the pandemic, although you should
n’t forget that the
costs have also increased again by 25-30%
and today we are
back in many cases to the
wheel level of before  Pandemic, which is a
small problem with increased costs,
I mean for the service
you provide as an entrepreneur or
economically,
you can also read about it, you are also
paid relatively, let's say normally, actually
I would, if you were an alarm clock
during its development  then
you would have to earn millions yourself
yes, but I am not a fortress
banks and I am also very satisfied
with my job at Papa and I
also think that you are
actually paid very well for it okay
group or something looked at the numbers
is yes at  open everything to you too it is
of course a great salary for
normal citizens but for someone who
now has a result in the bold who
agrees but
he also took the risk for that because I
think our other side has to do that
too  really give in everyone is
now talking about the return they get
from the dividend but to be fair
they were also there when it was
difficult here we have already
talked about 2014/2015 16
then they invested three times in the
company although not
many invested in it  believed that they would get
some of it back at some point,
so I think you
ALWAYS have to comment on something
individual, but
they were there for a long time and yes, they are
now getting a very
reasonable return,
um,
are you there  with the gentleman boldly
personally in exchange or
does someone from his from
his from his company or have
contact with us personally I mean we
can maybe meet as many times a
year yes and then mostly over
breakfast or something and because he
just  really interested and you
have to say that when we made important
strategic decisions
over the last ten years,
he always
supported us, always in general, there are
really
entrepreneurial personalities in shipping, that's
unbelievable, yes, if you look at him lightly
the farther away I think there is
a big speech in Italy that is
100% family owned and finally great
honor I mean you are probably talking
about MSC and they and family I mean
they are by the way yes I mean they are
originally Italian
built from nothing  more and nowadays,
of course, there is a lot more talk about what
you can imagine when you
hear your results now, what kind of
results they have had in recent years,
because that
simply belongs to the companies as a family, I
think nobody talks about it
because  one is always surprised that there
are people who somehow hold shares in
digital companies that are then somehow
worth 10 billion, you lose the family
then 30 billion in a year,
the result is there is one for your
pocket,
although I think what you usually see
with such families, they don't do that  Money
in the company because they are trying
to invest it again, yes, and to
develop the business further, and one
should not forget that the
same family also had very, very
difficult times during a number of crises,
because of course there were also huge ones at the beginning of the pandemic
Insecurities yes and yes now you have
also been lucky you have to
say in fairness and what you see in
family businesses in contrast to more
people is that most of what is
earned there simply does not go to the
others but simply goes back
to the company and you them  last few years
you can see when it comes to
family or
MSC the abyss of the family
simply invested a lot to
further strengthen the business they
believed in it even during the crisis
ordered new ships the expanded the fleet
took over companies when
nobody would have done it I mean  The ones
that go there are simply there that
invest significantly more I
think my MSC has now
bought about 300 additional ships and also
ordered a number of new ones
and and also topic has
invested properly but sometimes in other
things too  it
's easy
[music]
works to expand even further
that you somehow go to airlines or
a forwarding agency what before the
topic is not actually for us yes to be
fair we don't believe
that the forwarding agency is something for a
shipping company and the Sina are going along with it
Actually not an aircraft either, I
know that some of our colleagues are
doing it or have done it,
how it ends somehow it is
also exciting for the market and for the customers
that not everyone has the same
strategy and that means investing even more in digital
to build trading platforms, so to speak, so I
recently had someone from Foto or
the founder of Porto there, so maybe you know
a German
unicorn, a company that, so to speak, through
which you can then trade digitally
and then connect these forwarding companies,
so that’s the end of it
to make a web platform something like that for
you to enter the digital world even
more we are already entering the digital world more
if you look at the
digital tools we have then it has
also developed very strongly over the
last few years, even if we look at how
many employees we have the
IT department that has also
developed strongly we also have and John
Fähnchen in India with the
IT companies we
bought another IT company in India we
hired people here in Hamburg but also
in Poland and India that’s why  we are
also doing more and more yes, because with it
or digitization it simply has to be
in the freedom of chec even if it
is a traditional industry and you can see that
too, I mean I was
at an event yesterday and they
talked about it and said okay here
is a company  they
made the productivity as enormous
as it was in the last 25 years, it
quadrupled it, I took a look,
okay, by chance, how is it with us
yesterday evening and then
you can see that our productivity has
also quadrupled, somehow the
last one  25 years and that is 90%
digitization what is that, for
example, concrete, so where to
invest, what is it, I mean, I
know that you can see from the outside that you
can then book online with you, but there
are probably
a lot of processes in the background  I mean,
all these processes can be done and
we still have a lot of work ahead of us, but
almost all of them can be digitized,
the registration process, the
booking process, the documentation,
invoicing, billing,
payment solutions,
tracking, tracing, there are so many things
that you can automate
and do  we also where it
is possible and that is why we are
now able
to deliver a significantly higher level of productivity,
so it was 25 years ago, but
sometimes if you
read about shipping as a normal media consumer
then you are surprised that things
give you something  where you thought 100 years dead,
for example pirates, so there is
always the news in Somalia
that ships are somehow being
attacked by
pirates, what do I need,
basically, we don't talk about the subject,
yes, but it's like that  the
whole topic
I would say safety for our course
on board the ships is also a
big topic for us yes and that is not
trivial yes and in the end we have
a responsibility to do what we
can to protect our people and
that  we do too and we are just
like everyone else not immune yes for
such things and you are right such
things unfortunately still happen that
means you also get
a call like that and then you hear there is a
ship wanting to be attacked yes me
It's not like that, but I'm just saying that
you have to take a lot of precautions to
ensure that the that the big
remains security and you can never
do enough and that's a topic
that we're already very concerned about because there is
at  So we put the
following card in your office for you then
interface where you can see for
all your ships all are straight yes I
can I mean I can log in there and
see why such ships are to be fair
I almost never do that yes because it brings me
I honestly don't have to say that much
if I now know if I'm
pushing forward right now or for Rotterdam
if that's nice yes
probably looks nice on the
screen but more I do with it
rather less that's but that our
colleagues him in  fruit area or in the
network team the employees in your are
of course very busy which port
is the most important for you i
would say
Hamburg is probably still very very important for us yes
but in europe for example
rotterdam is also an incredibly important
location i have for  us okay and then
port in South America and then USA then yes
I mean and also in Asia Asia of
course always Shanghai you
then have Singapore for incredibly
incredibly important chevel Ali for
example also important for us Tanga is
important for us in Italy Genoa in
America New York but also all Long
Beach Vancouver in South America Katarina
Santos
600 ports a week yes but
of course there are quite a few helpers who
are more important to us because they are for our
hub this is Hamburg the
red ladies this is Tanga
these are New  York it's going away, yes Hamburg,
so of course I'm following as Hamburg
got, but for Germany
Hamburg is already the most important port and
the port will have that in the future, so to speak,
or there are discussions here
about the Elbe deepening that might
have to be or the modernity of the
port  so that's why I think it's but
maybe that's generally you're more
positive negative think the port does
have a future yes I think it
's also important that you
're actually realistic about what's
possible I mean 10 or 15
years ago we still have it  I talked about the
port with 25 million tu or something like that,
in my opinion, there won't be any in Hamburg,
yes, then you simply have
some geographical disadvantages
compared to Rotterdam or
depreciate yes, and in the long run it will also
be the case that there will be more cargo in it
Mediterranean is unloaded and then
the train goes to southern Germany, for
example, because then you are simply
much faster and I think that’s
why it’s important
to focus on things where you say
I’m really strong and Hamburg has that
too  sure its strong and
what can Hamburg do well no Hamburg
has, for example, a very
important role for us when it comes to the
traffic
from and to South America on the Atlantic
traffic India traffic far east
traffic partially
and there is, for example, the application on
the railway in  Hamburg is very good, yes, and
that helps us too, but I would
still advocate that the helpers
in Germany work better
together because I think the
real competition in Hamburg is
not Wilhelmshaven or Bremen, yes, the
real competition, but there
is actually this famous
müllin  -islands that are actually somewhere
more where a lot of rubbish is
floating around and that it is clearly there that
I mean there is
an incredible amount of rubbish yes in the ocean to be
fair we have here in
day-to-day business
we don’t have much of a problem with that
okay there is  because something that is causing you
some problems now, apart from pirates,
otherwise the ships are sailing
quite smoothly or are there
some disappearing or or
currents or winds or so how must the
challenge I think the
biggest challenge that many people
sometimes underestimate is simply
the weather, yes  because I think in winter
it's on the Atlantic where we have a lot
it's mostly relatively stormy more
and that gives the ships
some difficulties of
course we try to avoid that or
avoid it more but
unfortunately that can't always be avoided and if you
you're such a big ship and there's
wind force 10 or 12, that's not
exactly funny, yes, and there are also other
weather issues, for
example in South America, you usually have
problems with the waves, yes, and when the
waves are higher than a certain point
you are not allowed to let the helpers in and that
also leads to delays and the
Middle East, for example, you have them there is
quite a lot of fog, yes in
some months and if there is fog
you cannot go into the port,
so the weather is probably the
most important thing
Reason for deviations from
yes the normal
of digitalization of the processes still
correct innovation or newcomers in the
industry so all of a sudden mask comes to you
and he finds the car industry new
so to speak when was that the last new
player to come but there is in
the shipping industry  also something that
really new companies have emerged
that weren’t there before with the new
process or you ca
n’t actually enter this market anymore because
it’s just so powerful I mean that I
think it’s just difficult to get in there
anymore  because the talk
is now so big yes that in order to
actually get on board
you would actually have to take over a shipping company
yes only to buy 250 ships yourself
or even 100 ships for 150
million each that is quite a
yes uh that that I already have a real
sum  when it comes to innovation, the
container itself was of course a huge
innovation 50 years ago
it is still very efficient what
you can see today that the containers are always
I say more and more intelligent mean
we start, for example,
all containers
are refrigerated containers or standard
containers from with  tracking devices yes
that will be in the course of this year and
hopefully at the end of the year 80
to 90% of the boxes will also
have tractors and then you always know exactly
where the box is and that way you can
definitely control the fleet better but
things like that like you  you
could now assume that there are unfortunately always
autonomous ships where
someone with a
remote control will not give you ships across the world
I can imagine that at
some point you will say, okay, I will drive
autonomously because
the labor costs account for a high proportion of the total costs
when you talk about ships that
cost 165 or 200 million, yes, and they
still have millions in operating costs
every year anyway, and man  talks about
greeting where you can maybe replace five people then
it's a completely different one the
relationship is completely different the
actually the savings messenger yes if
you would automate everything completely
more is very small yes that's
the first and the second is
so much  Risks that you also have to cover with it,
I mean, if you
just think about how
much the goods are worth that
are all on the ship, then you have to
ask yourself is it really
worth this investment, also because the market
is for something like that  tell me if you
made all container ships autonomous
then you would have a market of 5000 systems yes yes
I know there is always talk about it
but if you just
take a look at it then I
can see the probability and
like to create entry about it
is the one from whom you
charter the ships so I mean there are
always startups like this I have
followed in Hamburg years ago there was
a company that then bought a ship
and you others he is about it new
players are coming in mine there are
of course many players yes  in this
market I mean there are
one or the other here in Germany but there
are also the Greeks, for
example, there are large tons uh these
are not new
these are not new entries yes and yes
someone can buy a ship  and
trying to despair but that did
n't change the mark but that's
also an added value, so to speak, that
you don't use yourself, so to speak, but
someone simply buys ships and
rents them out, that's a
different device
between the one hand, the big ships
we usually have ourselves, yes  and
then we rent one or the other
ship simply because that gives us a certain
flexibility if we have 250 ships
ourselves then we tend to have to
invest more capital and our
flexibility will then only be and
you just don't have to do that, especially don't
remember cyclical  Business like here
again
a contract just extended no
2027 what will happen in the future
when the years come again what do
you expect so the
result will go down so it is
somehow hard to
beat now what is there where do you think if
that I know  not that I would like to
know if you get the question
more often of course but I do
n't know that I hope that we will be
able to earn back our capital costs in the long run but I mean we
have just had a few years now in which
we have made a lot of money  now
the next couple of years could
be really difficult again that
different as well as that more attractive to
shipping yes sometimes things go well
sometimes things are less good and
actually never boring yes and we
will also
try to further expand the business over the next few years
in particular  when it comes to terminus
or infrastructure and when it comes to
further digitization your job
is also very strong to
see what can you forge now for
cooperation where you can
maybe buy not very strong
but a safe part of it always via
the  over the years if you like actually
trying to win everyone then
you end up having it's a simple
deal you only have two choices
either you buy me ship yes or
you buy someone else yes and
we decided we'd
say okay we don't  just
out of buying crazy new ships but
we would always
look at opportunities to maybe take over the one or the
other company that is
n't doing so well and where we
're just the better owner and as well as
expanding our business
when it comes to actual  Participation
and raising and doing what
you have to bet on buy a share now because
listening to the podcast says okay sounds
exciting what do you want to say that you believe the
core the core
that you had to have as a
shareholder who is now new to
the current valuation of what you have to do
but nowadays the
valuation is of course also very strongly
driven by the dividend that is
expected but also by the value of
von Harburg people if you add up the value that
we have in
replacement and also in cash
then you would too
would do that alone yes that
would that would also lead to a good
stock market value i think in the end
if you invest in shipping
you have to believe that
value economy will continue to grow if you
then believe that value economy will
continue to grow in the long run yes and  you do
n't invest with a horizon of
three months or six months but
in the longer term okay then you can
consider getting involved in the Indian case
because the ones you just listed
the ships are assets the
containers the employees and
technology the brand too
so Hapag people are one of those  Traditional brand and I'm
told something like that I'm a child
and can't from Hamburg but you
hear people somehow does it have a
value or does it actually not matter to you in the
end I think it definitely has
a value yes it's not a value the so in
the  The balance sheet is there, but I'm completely with
you, I think so too, but people have a
good reputation in the industry and also with
many customers and in the end that
helps, in the end I think it stands
for quality for reliability
for
stability and that's just important
and there are many customers who in the long run would
probably prefer hapag-loud
for ships with some
new drives from yes also don't know
if they've been there for more than two years
at the end now if you introduce yourself
but 27 do you stay in Hamburg or do you
go again  back to Holland i
mean i don't know either i mean i
have a contract until 2012 27
you have to decide at some point whether
it will be extended yes or no
if it is extended stay safe in
hamburg if it is not extended
i know that would be wise  not
maybe i mean i
feel very comfortable in hamburg my
wife also maybe here with me
but maybe we are with
my family in holland that will
tell the future always bad
to plan five or ten years ahead
Most of the time it all turns out
differently anyway, thank you very much for the
update for the insights into such a
different industry, um well, I definitely
learned more than in the normal
podcast, um simply because I knew it,
thank you very much, ciao